your film the queen of hollywood
boulevard
you say is the anti la la land you said
jokingly
which i think is great um i'm curious if
you feel that film
your film is more realistic than la la
land
for those watching from another part of
the country or world and
seeing la and i know you've talked about
you love the underbelly which i also do
too there's like a weird fascination
with that
um do you think some of the queen of
hollywood boulevard is a much more truer
tale
than la la land or no oh i absolutely
think that
queen is a lot more of a truer uh tale
than lala land i think lala land is
one of the more uh i mean i i have big
uh i love the last 10 minutes of the
movie because it's he's a very good
filmmaker
there's no doubt about it his chops are
amazing
but knowing that and filming in many of
the same locations that they filmed in
la la land
it's as if the world two feet away and
two feet to the left and two feet to the
right don't exist
in his version of hollywood because and
in my version of hollywood
which is where i live and i've spent a
long time documenting
it i think there is a reality that is in
front of you there that you have to
um look at you know i mean hollywood is
probably
has one of the most concentrated um
population of homelessness in the
country
and i don't think there's a shot in la
la land that shows
one person beyond even homeless maybe
slightly impoverished or not dressed
impeccably
in that area or in anywhere in la um
[Music]
but i just think you know it's different
point of views i think some people are
fascinated i think we were dealing with
very similar themes
um you know the idea of the the dream
of success and the dream of fame
and i think there's just two very
different
paths that maybe you can take when you
start looking at at that world and what
it's like you know for
you know my film was like the other side
what happens to a woman who comes to
la to be an actress 40 years later and
she never became that actress but she
still made something of herself even if
it's a very small
enclave and echelon that she inhabits
and
maybe that's not the most pc or
you know nice place in the world that
she haven't you know it's a strip club
it's on the you know the the shady side
of the street
but it's still hers and
i think in la la land you have a lot of
people living a dream that was a much
more selfish and much more self-serving
and did not in any way try to
realistically look at hollywood i mean
this street where
it's so funny because we both have the
shot have have the same shot of
the mural of celebrities in it
in the film and
that street of and on hollywood and
wilcox is one of the most
like places of like alyssa's illicit
salacious actions i've ever seen in my
life
like you know um and
i wanted my film to feel the way that
street smells
and i think he wanted that street to
exist
in some other universe and i think
that's maybe the difference between us
you know
but um yeah i mean i don't know if it's
more realistic i think there's also
those people that come here
and they realize their dreams and they
find their
fame and they they do whatever it takes
to become that person
i just don't necessarily care that much
for those type of stories
i'm with you on that and i thought it
was beautiful what you said earlier
you said there was like two different
realities
right sort of like and the other one
doesn't see the other reality i think
that's a very true statement about
living in la i mean you could work with
someone and they could be living in a
completely different reality than you
are um and you're still inhabiting like
the same workplace
oh absolutely i mean i didn't have to do
with la i get work cars all the time
people don't walk around
people don't come into communication
with each other that much i mean
obviously when i walk everywhere like i
really like
enjoy being that's part of the reason i
live in hollywood because it's like
living in a city i'm from new york
so it reminds me of that a little bit
you know in new york you're crammed in
subways
together you're getting cabs together
you bump into each other
you're just you're always interacting
well in la i think there's this
a little bit this like rejection of
other people like you don't you just
live in your bubble and whatever you do
in there is fine
and i wanted the opposite i wanted to
make like a movie about a woman of the
people
and i think that in something like la la
land it's just it's not about
any interaction to the people it's that
their own world is everything you know
at the same time i think it really
executes it very well
and tell us what the story is about
about is queen man about queen
yeah uh the queen valley boulevard is
about a um
an aging strip club owner on the eve of
her 60th birthday and
she runs a strip club in hollywood it's
her love her joy it's everything and
she's a single mom she brought up her
son who'd like better or for worse
is her other joy in life and
a man from her past duke played by roger
gwenevere smith comes
to reclaim a debt on how uh clearly
it i keep it mysterious and vague
because that's just sure how i am
but um you don't have to give away yeah
basically it's it's it's about how
it's how she got the club and now it's
time to repair debt on her 60th birthday
and she has to run a gauntlet basically
through the
underbelly of los angeles to not only
save her club but also save her son
who's being held as ransom
wow yeah and the the protagonist is
played by your mom
yes the protagonist queen mary is played
by my mom
rosemary hawk's child and she's in every
single frame of the film
and she killed it
you said something in another interview
about seeing the movie the crying game
and that you learn from either seeing it
or not being able to see parts of it
you learned about boundaries and
censorship from the point of like an
audience or something
i was just wondering if you could expand
on that because i thought that was
fascinating oh cool story and everything
yeah well so sorry i have a predilection
to make violent movies
i've always been attracted to them uh
kind of
harsh realities and violent instances
um and that's where
creatively i i am attracted to
so it all started and i at one point
pinpointed this moment
uh my mom my mom was a single mom
bringing me up in new york
and she wanted to go see the film the
crying game
um over at the angelica film
the angelica film center in new york
city
so she took me because she couldn't get
a babysitter so i went with her and
there's a very violent scene in the
crying game
with uh god what's a great irish actor's
name
i can't remember his name steven ray
there's a violent
uh scene with steven ray and
a uh and the love interest who's also a
transvestite
and my mom newt was coming so she said
hey
she took me she took me outside the
theater
and said can you you know you
sit with an usher and i'm gonna go watch
the scene because i wanted to see the
film
but she knew it was coming because her
friends had told her so you know so i
knew well i'm not supposed to watch this
like i gotta see this
so in the doorway of the angelica film
center was a portal
that you could see into the theater and
i watched the scene through the porthole
out of the door with no sound and it was
that moment that i knew
i wanted to make i wanted to be part of
transgressive
cinema where i and i couldn't put a word
on it then but now i think i understand
more is
that i i wanted to to break down that
that doorway between the audience
between what you're not supposed to see
and what you can see
and i think that's what i learned in
that moment was this idea that as an
audience member you know there's these
violent moments and were allowed these
glimpses into them and there was like a
certain voyeurism
sort of a certain taboo that i wasn't
being allowed in on
and that's all i ever wanted to do since
then in these films
so yeah that moment was very um
informative to my to to later you know
20 years later when i started
i actually got the chance to make a
movie and i realized
why do i have this predilection for
violence why do i want to
always push it because it was something
that was taken away from me that i
couldn't have
and that even drew me closer to it
that's interesting because it goes back
to what you said earlier about like
living these two different realities and
and how there's people that could be
right next to you and they're living a
different reality than you
and i can remember being younger and i
grew up in somewhat of a conservative
town and there were kids that i played
with that
weren't allowed to watch public
television and to me i wasn't you know i
was watching three's company and that
was
probably too progressive for my age you
know and so i just think that's
interesting that
that having been sort of kept from you
oh yeah i mean that's what's fascinated
me right and i think that's like
kind of what's created great i mean you
look at scorsese or paul schrader right
both grew up in very
conservative religious households right
paul schrader didn't see a film until he
was over 18.
and all his films kind of deal with
violent this lack of faith this
alienated outsider in a world that
doesn't want him
so it's totally affected them i on the
other hand was almost allowed to see too
much
so this moment of not being allowed to
see something was
really and being inhibited really to me
prove that there were boundaries that
people didn't want you to cross as the
viewer but i wanted to cross them
so i think yeah it's the same thing
right like we we're products of our
environment i think that might push us
totally in the other direction than
intended by
you know the person in charge very true
yeah and you were raised by two artists
which is interesting because most people
it seems like a lot of people are raised
by people that aren't artists and then
they prevent their kids from wanting the
arts because they want to
save them from some of the the harsh
realities of doing anything creative
so how was that being raised by by
either one person or knowing that two
parents that you had were creative i
mean it was a pretty
interesting childhood for sure um
you know my mom and dad they came here
from south africa in the 70s to escape
apartheid
and not they were just very
anti-apartheid and anti-political
systems of africa
at the time so they came here and
my dad was a filmmaker my mom was an
actress and you know eventually they
went their different ways
and my dad moved out to la and became a
filmmaker and he always told me
he was like you don't want to do this he
was like go be a doctor be a lawyer
whatever you do do not become a
filmmaker
so of course i was like well i'm
becoming a filmmaker that dad
said no um probably should have listened
to him and you basically have to be a
lawyer half the time in this industry
anyway
but um and then my mom on the other hand
was extremely supportive and i lived
with her most my life in new york
and she was always you know like be
creative helping me create supporting
creativity
bought me a still camera when i was very
young that i used all the time to take
photos with and
that was kind of my first inlet into
film so it was interesting and and then
i also watched my dad
who you know he had a lot of struggles
he made some great films he had some
struggles with films and he's
and it was you know the industry wasn't
always the best to him and
and it changed and you know he's always
managed to keep up with it and do his
thing
but so i had a very much a firsthand
glimpse
into also you know this is a really hard
industry this is
and that it goes back to la la land
right i think la la land
starts with the thesis that it's a heart
industry but that makes it seem like
it's very easy
and for me i think there's a lot of us
that you know we put a lot
we let a lot ride on the filmmaking on
being filmmaker being an artist
and when it doesn't work out it really
hurts
and i saw that firsthand as well and
i've had it happen to me firsthand
with different you know with you put
something out there and maybe the
responses and what you wanted and it's
like your child
so yeah as i was very lucky to have the
support of parents and i was lucky to
have an insight and i'm pretty crazy
that i wanted to go do this
but i couldn't imagine doing anything
else in the world
i get the sense and maybe i told you
this one we had you on the panel but
that you've always been like two decades
ahead
of people like even growing up was that
hard for you i'm just assuming i
shouldn't assume but i could see that in
you that you were like more advanced
than maybe
some other kids i don't know if i was i
mean i went through a lot of honestly i
have a lot of personal trials and
tribulations i went through
growing up so i think
creatively i got i i was i was allowed
to express myself at an early age and
there was no pushback against that and
that was very important
on the other hand i think with that i
was a terrible student i was
not great uh always socially younger you
know got in a lot of trouble
um kind of rested all that stuff like so
that came with that
so i think you know there's a give and
take to everything but i am very
grateful that i got to be creative
at a young age and that was supported
and that no one ever really pushed me in
any other direction
and i feel blessed
in that way because i know a lot of
people who are amazing filmmakers now
and it took a lot
you know they had to reject their
family's wishes and move away from
home and go far away and they're super
successful and
really fantastic artists but there came
from the opposite where they really had
to push back against the world that they
were brought up
so you know i think it's you know the
luck of the draw a little bit
i think on your website um you had a
quote that
just said that um you have to be
obsessed
or maybe it was a q a you have to be
obsessed to make this work
so i just think that's interesting i
mean because
if you know that you had struggles
before sometimes people
take an easier path but if i think if
you've dealt with risk and
just always feeling like stuff's not
going to work out then you're willing to
take sort of a long shot
i don't know yeah i mean i think you
have to be obsessed like there's
there's no get rich quick scheme in the
film at least in my version of this film
industry like
you want to make personal films or
you're not getting rich the next day
when it comes out
you probably have to put your own money
your own credit your own time your own
family your own relationships
online and that's only worth it if you
are
absolutely obsessed and no one can tell
you to be obsessed you're just gonna be
obsessed
it's not it's gonna overwhelm you and
take you and then in the end of the day
you're gonna have to give put it out in
the world and when it comes out there
you're done
you know you've done your job and yeah i
really do
think that this is a film industry of
uh that filmmaking more than the
industry because the industry is a whole
other thing but i think almost anyone
who works in the film industry
is absolutely crazy you have to be right
yeah you just there's no reason to you
can work on a bank you can have a great
life
but for me it's kind of like i get one
shot at this life and like this is what
i love and i
even like many days you know only have a
hundred dollars in my bank account but
it doesn't matter
because i get to make a movie i get to
work i get to write
i get to have great conversations with
people it opens
outlets in your life that no money or
career opportunities could open for you
well i know i've known a lot of people
that work
corporate jobs that aren't happy and
then it manifests into
office politics and you know because
you're dealing with the same set of
people same dynamic almost every day
and i think that people start to get
crazy there too
i think it's just a contained crazy
absolutely but
you know i think also like you know
we're all trying our best to survive
in this crazy world and there's you know
all the rules that people give us seem
to change all the time
so you know i think there's no i think
there was a time in my life where i used
to think
you know oh you're gonna do a corporate
job you know whatever that's you but
it's all it's all just your path and
like your journey
and as a filmmaker like you're gonna
you're gonna be miserable a lot of the
time you're gonna be sad you're gonna
think you're terrible at what you do i
mean
i was going through it recently like i'm
editing a new film and some days like i
just want to press the delete button on
the whole thing you know
like i just don't want it i don't even
want to look at a frame of it anymore
but you got it because it's yours and
and honestly the only reason you have to
is because if you don't no one else will
do you think that comes from being so
close to it every day because now you
can get sick of something even if it's
excellent but it's just like you're
facing it every day and it goes back to
the same thing with the workplace
you're in the same place every day so
then stuff manifests
oh absolutely i think it's all about you
know
i'm actually it's so funny you say
because i'm very much going through this
process that i'm struggling with right
now i have a new film
that i've been making and i i've i wrote
directed i shot it and i'm editing it
and a lot of that was out of just
a financial necessity because when
you're doing small low budget films
there's just
certain voids you you may have to fill
along the way
b is that's just the way i imagine
making the movie i think that was
it was kind of this mercurial process i
saw and i said i want to try this
and uh and again it comes back to
obsession i'm obsessed
and uh control freak and i think almost
all filmmakers are control freaks
actually everyone i met and i'm very
messy in my life
but my films is where i get to like be
the control freak
and um and going back to that
i think you get so close i i was so
funny i was talking to a friend today he
said
how are you doing on the edit and i go
dude i'm so deep in the woods i don't
even know
which end i'm coming out on and he was
like he was like yeah but you know this
one day we'll
this will end and you're gonna come out
on one side of the woods so
just keep going and that's kind of you
know the uh
you know it's like the elizabeth warren
uh uh
uh what's her her the elizabeth warren
slogan you know
uh she persisted you know that's kind of
the way filmmaking is you have to
persist you have to persist at every
step of it
but yeah it is very hard to be close and
it's very hard to detach yourself from
something that
you really love you know and let it go
in every edit is you letting go of
something you love
and then it turns to you hating it and
then you're kind of in a crazy place
well with the queen of hollywood how was
that once you screened it
and then i think you have distribution
for it right yeah so
and then like the whole sort of sexiness
of filming it is over
the editing part where maybe it's more
dramatic and then now it's out in the
world
what is that like the good and the bad
of that
wow um making queen was
one of the most if not the most
transformative experience
i had as a human being um there was a
lot that went
of reasons why i made that film i was
going through some very personal
dark situations around me
and i basically was like i to understand
this world i have to make a film
at this point because i don't really
know where else to go
and then i made it i shot it you know
getting the whole process every process
is hard right like you have no money
you're begging people for money
and the amazing thing is people help you
and that's one of the things i the first
step i learned along the way
i guess to go through it is that people
were there and really excited to be part
of it
from the get-go and a small team formed
and then a bigger team formed and then
we were shooting and it was the most
amazing experience ever
and then i edited that film for almost a
year
i was so obsessed and so
not sure of what it was and i had
another editor kelly mcgillicuddy on it
for a couple months and my producers
matt and jeff they were also editors so
they'd come in and edit like it was kind
of this
crazy process and we'd send it to
festivals and we'd get rejected and then
a festival would say
no we want you actually we're not going
to take you just a crazy i mean i have
many stories no one's you know you never
know and then
at a party i met uh michael rep she runs
dark star pictures
and we just hit it off and i sent them
the film
i mean i went through every other
channel in the world you're supposed to
go through
and i met a guy at a party who was like
i dig this film
let's do it and you know he worked
really closely with me
distributed it came out in theaters
played a bunch of cool festivals
it you know and i don't think you're
ever satisfied you always think you know
you're so obsessed that you're like this
is the greatest thing in the world
and it it's great to you but
you know there's a lot of films out
there there's a lot of art out there and
you just have to let it be and you have
to let it live
you have to let it find its own life and
that was a big experience i learned but
i loved it i mean there's nothing
you know there's there's honestly
nothing more satisfying than being able
to go
on like amazon and just type your film
in
and it comes up and you know what it
doesn't matter if one person sees it or
one million people see it like
that's your baby and it's out in the
world and
it's all worth it just just to let it to
know that it lives
and that it will live but it's a lot of
work you know and it's
it's not always that's the thing that it
goes back to the la la land
uh statement right it kind of keeps
going back to that which is like
that film tells us that like if you do
work and you find success
it will all be great not as great as you
thought because you could have had this
other
you gave up love but it's still pretty
great
and it's hard the whole process is hard
and it's difficult and it's
alienating but we again we do it because
we're obsessed crazy people
and we feel we have a story to tell and
those stories are important that
anyone who has them tells them
sometimes the film just finds its place
so that was a statement i heard you say
an interview and i think just a second
ago did the queen of hollywood boulevard
find the place you thought it would or
did
people actually find something new about
it that was fascinating to you that
you're like oh okay wow
it didn't find the place i thought it
would but they liked this about it
yeah i mean i think i mean i think you
kind of have to go
into every film shooting for the stars
you know everyone wants me in sundance
everyone wants to be in south by
everyone wants to be in cannes and
venice
and there's a million reasons why you
might not get in there but
you don't get it and then you gotta see
where does it where can
it live you know and i found that
through a series of curators and
programmers like boston underground film
festival
and beyond fest and a bunch of place
mammoth and and these places which were
the first places to accept it
um it started finding this really cool
audience of real cinema lovers you know
of you know i didn't really see it when
i made it as even though it was based
off all these 70s cult films i loved i
didn't see it as like a
genre cult movie um
and that's where it started living and
it started finding this really cool
audience of people
and yeah i mean
it's it's so it's funny so many things
run through my head when you say that
like
to find it's i think it's still
finding its place i think it's in its
release on online now and it's on
shutter it's on all these
you know shutter which i love and it's
on amazon it's on 2b all these different
uh outlets for it i think it's starting
to find a cool core group of
followers that really like it you know
and i'd really
i think it's really cool that you know
maybe
some films have a million people that
like it maybe one film has
100 people who like it but they love it
and it means a lot to me
that they love it and i get em like i
got a few emails recently
just out of the blue or facebook
messages from people and they were like
this film just like
hit me like i don't know what it is and
i've never met these people in my life i
never had anyone reach out to me
so it's kind of a
a surreal a surreal experience even on a
small level because the film didn't
become a giant success right it didn't
become
come a breakout hit that
you may have i don't know if i ever
thought that's what it was going to be
but that
you know the opposite of what what uh
the the
not the opposite um i'm trying to say
succinctly
i think it's still finding it's it's
core audience
and the film is of the film's audience
is evolving
all the time and i think that's what i
mean when a film finds its place and it
finds its life
they're they're almost like living
organisms movie they
they go they work their way through a
nervous system of content
media of technology now and
i think audience members are very smart
at this moment
and they have a lot of options and i'm
very grateful that any audience member
chooses to see my
watch my film when they have tens of
thousands of other ones
and the fact that it has started finding
a core audience and finding an audience
of
people that have even reached out to me
about the movie
is really special and yeah it does go
the film
a film finds its place you can't force
it i like that
and i think you also have talked about
you want to make movies that create
dialogue
so is it that you're okay if somebody
doesn't like it as long as it's creating
some interesting conversation because
not everything even we put out people
get upset over the smallest thing
but i'm actually satisfied when it's
creating a conversation
yeah i had a college professor they used
to say that making art was
uh to incite discourse and
i truly think that's all that kind of
matters in the end of the day
um you know good or bad
that's your chinese dinner you know was
the food good
was the food bad films are much more
complicated that than that even films
that don't seem
seem to be that way all art is all art
is asking you to just go dig a little
deeper
so nothing makes me happier than
watching
then hearing or seeing people talk about
my film i don't care if you hate it
the worst thing i could do is be
immediate i could do and i think any
filmmaker or artist to do is be mediocre
and we die in mediocrity and i think
right now
in this crazy content laden world that
we're in
i think our biggest enemy as artists
is mediocrity and that's my goal as a as
a filmmaker i don't necessarily think i
make great movies
uh i don't some people hate them
and i'm okay with that because i just
want if you're gonna talk about it if
it's gonna bring up conversation
if it's something that in any way
incites you to discuss
anything i'm happy and that's just how i
feel you know
did you see the documentary on chris
burton he was the artist
who shot i've never seen him but i know
his art he did the
lack of lamps yeah and he got shot in
the arm and he made the train set over
there
right well i think part that was part of
his uh art thing was to do the shooting
yeah yeah yeah film him shooting it
getting shot in the arm
right right yeah i love that see i love
performance artists and and i love that
type of art and i don't think i'm that
shocking in any way i'm not like
gaspar noe or someone like that but even
though those are my i love
those filmmakers john waters and
gasparno a real transgressive cinema
you know that pushed us harmony corrine
but i think yeah
an artist like chris burton um
is just like that you know recently at
the venice biennale
this artist whose name i can't remember
he brought to this venice biennale
and put it in a museum in an art gallery
a boat that migrants
died on oh wow on their way to greece i
believe
and he put it in the in the gallery and
a lot of people were like you know
that's exploitative that's whatever i go
well you're gonna talk about it so
you can say whatever you want about
about the artist but he did his job
his job is done now now it's your
responsibility
as critics as audience to go discuss it
and you figure it out
so yeah well in a day and age when
people are getting arrested for helping
people in the desert and giving them
water you know that are trying to
whatever your feelings are they're still
there and they're whatever and
and now people are being surveilled
for helping people so that's an
interesting statement yeah totally it's
a giant statement that he's making and i
believe we are living in a
very polarizing time of like on one hand
you do have like you're saying like the
surveillance state
and the and third world living is going
into the worst it's ever been the
discrepancy between rich and poor
is terrible and there's all these and
these are all things that
without knowing that people are
analyzing in film you know in a horror
movie
that is about clowns killing homeless
people
it might actually be it might actually
have some subtext
to this idea of politics so that's like
my point about film i just think
we we deserve to the filmmakers to just
look a little further into what they're
doing sometimes
i know chris burton he faced a lot of
backlash not just from
non just not not just from patrons but
from the art world and i think it
you know he became quite upset and
isolated himself a little bit but it
also drove him further into his work
so you know that's that's the thing do
you become so
um i don't know if avant-garde is the
right word but successful at creating
this conversation
but then it creates that that's the part
i hate to see an artist that it
shuns them it makes them shut in the
world you know well i think people
forget how sensitive artists are
you know and i'm not apologizing for
artists because as an artist you get to
live
the greatest life you know the blessed
life you know you get to
create and that's a beautiful thing
and i think but there's a certain and
yang to that
and artists are very sensitive and they
take their work very seriously i think a
lot
and now in the day of twitter
and and social media everyone's a critic
right and even more than that with
chris burton where people really uh
ostracized him but at the same time that
became his legacy he became a legend
because of that you know so who knows
what the
you know in in the end it's it's it it
kind of
goes back to idea like a film finds its
place like art finds its place as well
and whether that's good or bad to people
it's kind of hard to judge you know look
at how many great i mean it can get dark
for a second but look how many great
artists have
killed themselves right people who you
thought were on top of the world
and and they they you know because we
don't we never know about someone's
inner monologue so that again it just
comes back with
art and with film and with media and i
think
one of the things i as a filmmaker hope
to do just a little bit is just
ask an audience to be like just talk
about it just discuss it just
just spend know that like these stories
are for you
and we love that you enjoy them
and we love for you to discuss them
is being a filmmaker an artist or i know
you had
you said it's it's kind of two worlds
well i think that
i think it's really interesting in
today's world like yeah i think all
filmmakers are artists
but i think it's also what's amazing
about film is it's so technology driven
that you also have to be a technician
and you have to understand the format
understand the medium and understand the
complexities of all the layers
of making a movie you know it's kind of
you know what
why you know it's only been around 100
years and it's the synthesis of
photography and painting and novel
writing and sound
and music so that's what i've always
been attracted to is kind of taking
everything
i am attracted to and i love and be able
to like jumble it all together and
find a certain type of balance between
all these art forms
so i think a filmmaker is is definitely
an artist
but you know you're also a businessman
you're also a technician
you're also an audience member you have
to play
all these parts along the way and i
think of
a fear it's something that i got caught
in for a long time
and it almost came with making a movie
and trying and failing and trying and
failing
was being like i just have an artistic
vision i have to stick to microsoft and
all that but
it's not just about you it's about a
whole just a hundred you know
even on a small film there's 40 people
that go into making the movie
so i think it's about also knowing that
there's a lot of opinions a lot of other
people
that a film is bigger than you as an
artist
when you start making it it takes a lot
on a life of its own again
and so i think you need to find a
balance as a filmmaker not only as an
artist but also as a technician
also when you're lucky enough to be the
director someone who also can
guide uh all the other departments and
listen to the other departments
on because they and to the department
heads and all your other crew members
and everyone
because they also have opinions and
they're also personally invested in your
film
so i think in a way a film is a
collection of artists
even if they don't mean to be coming
together to create this story and bring
it to life
and you also said to be an attorney that
you didn't think that you didn't
can you just touch on that just uh when
when did you discover that and and
oh i mean filmmaking and contracts like
trying to get your film made
and having to make a deal with contracts
seem to go hand in hand right like you
have to
you know at all times everyone's trying
to protect themselves you're dealing
with
any amount of money it's still money and
you have to protect the person who's
giving you the money you have to protect
the film
from the money you have to make sure
that
you know everything's reasonable so you
and lawyers are very expensive
so it's a cost that at a point you you
know have to take on a little bit of
extra effort
to learn the business of films and the
law
and the law and what you can and can't
do and
and understand what you're getting
yourself into because in the end every
film is also
a company it's a little limited
liability corporation llc each one
so you have to know that
there's other factors involved that just
go beyond like i have a story to tell
right you know it's business as well and
it's not again it's not something
you know it's not becoming a millionaire
overnight but you still have investments
you still have
actors that are that they have to be
protected
and you have to make you know they they
have they're putting themselves out
there so they have clauses in their
contracts and you have to understand
their clauses
so that you also don't infringe upon
them when you're filming
um so yeah i think and then every step
of the way when you're
raising the money making the deals with
actors closing the deals
with your department heads um
distributing the movie
you're dealing with contracts in every
single facet
and if your film's big enough and you're
the director i'm sure you don't have to
deal with them but on these small budget
films which
uh we some i got i've been able to do
and i love doing
you have to take a little extra interest
into the legal side of it
so yeah i mean it just we've all read
and heard the horror stories
of you know people getting sued people
losing the rights to their film
it just happened to taran to terry
gilliam last year on
uh on the don quixote film you know he
lost the rights to the movie to a
producer because
they didn't realize there was a loophole
in the contract and
that was his baby you know he actually i
believe had a heart attack from it
when it first happened oh my goodness so
you know and that's a big film something
on these little films
it's hard it's it's a it's a crazy
business
what do you think story is going we
talked a little bit earlier about you
know this sort of crazy
political world that we're in gen extras
like me we weren't thinking about like
really facial recognition
and things that you know are very real
things that are going to be happening
and they're already happening
what if somebody's face is on a now now
a database and they're wrongly accused
and now their their lives
totally changed so but those weren't
things we were totally thinking about
maybe just they dabbled in
some sci-fi well i think you know
i think there's a lot of
i mean one of the beautiful things i
find about film is the way that film
has continually prophesied the future
uh in sci-fi in mystery and noir
in all these facets but i think right
now i guess in story i'm actually what
i've been seeing
is a really amazing um
re imagining of the structure of film
and of storytelling i think even in the
last six months i've started seeing
movies being
presented in a more commercial way that
are actually pretty advanced story wise
a lot of chinese cinema is really
pushing storytelling
um structurally and there's film long
day's journey in tonight which was one
of
really pushed the idea of how to tell a
story i think
in a whole new way and i think we get
into how it's
affecting i mean right now in film
we i we're we're entering almost like a
a a
a no-man's own of what's next right like
goes back to what you're saying about
ai special recognition but people were
dealing with that from the 50s you know
they were looking at
the possibilities of the future 2001 a
space odyssey was dealing with ai
you know there so we we've always looked
to film to help us understand the future
and i think anybody who makes a film has
to be a little bit of a futurist because
your film's
coming out at least a year later it's
not two to three years after you've made
it
so you're always having to look to the
future a little bit in each movie
but i think storytelling i think film
itself is is a very uh
rudimentary uh language that's it's
still in its like primitive stage and i
think what we're starting
starting to see now is people exploring
it
in all new ways than ever before because
the film
doesn't just live in a movie theater for
90 minutes now it lives on your phone
it lives in segments it lives in music
videos like film is a whole
new term i think
but in the idea of how do i think that
filmmakers are
attacking or kind of taking on the idea
of the future
i uh i think in the same way they always
have they always looked
i think that's what i love about film
they've always looked to the future
to help us on as audiences understand
what may come
and sadly sometimes they're right
and that's the scary thing right it's
like there's a lot of films that are
looking a lot more realistic than
when they were made you know um even
you know you even look at uh a big like
what was the big
the roland emmerich movie about climate
change he did in
night 2002 2003 uh
well not uh in inconveniences no that
was not
no no al gore just was giving us a
reality that no one listened to
right right that's true look at all
these films that we're dealing with you
know mad max
all these movies that we took as kind of
these popcorn flicks even though they
were always better than that
um are very much coming true right now
and i think they're going to come true a
lot faster than anyone realized
and i think as filmmakers now
we're having to look at
the reality that's next is a very scary
one
and i think that's why you're seeing
this
these films like us you know these
movies that are
are dark but resonating on a very large
global scale
so yeah and here philip k dick was
writing in his little hovel
i think he preferred to write like where
it was real dirty and messy a lot of
what he wrote
unfortunately has already sort of taken
place but you know
and struggled and i think he had to go
to a pet store to get his meat you know
and
that's where he absolutely and he he was
a pretty
you know reclusive dude philip cage but
look at scanner darkly
i mean we're not far from that we're not
we're at a point where
one of the biggest uh there was an
article that came out today that said
the three biggest threats to humankind
is climate change nuclear war
and a.i and phil kay dick was dealing
with ai in the 60s
right as was ray bradbury as was a lot
of those
those early science fiction writers
and it's interesting because it wasn't
just science fiction
right a lot of people taking on
political movies you know you look at
like a
snow piercer which only came out a
couple years ago which i just rewatched
and that doesn't seem as far away as it
once did you know a world
total where the climate outside is so
sub-zero that they have to live on a
train
that's propelled by that small poor
people
right right yeah and phil okay dickie he
well i wouldn't say he was persecuted by
any means but he definitely got some
scrutiny from
all sides including including the
government but he also
was you know sort of in the 60s in
berkeley
at a time was very um well i don't want
to get too political yeah but i think
on the other side of the spectrum
because i don't want to i mostly
labor too much in this political
darkness and
there's also great films is there for us
to escape that as well
sure and i think we have to remember
that there's two sides to
filmmaking it's not just to show us the
harsh realities of today but it's also
for us to get lost in another world
and enjoy it and have fun living in that
other world you know
and that for me is a big part of it a
lot of days
you know where i've been depressed or
not felt you know
necessarily up for it i've gone at 3 pm
to a movie
and you know it's just i've i've gotten
to just disappear for a little while and
i really relish
those moments and even if it's a
terrible film it's still that dark room
that move
you know and that goes back to the whole
experience of magic but that movie
theater experience
you're just in your world and it's just
you and sound and images and story
nothing's better so i really also on the
other hand
appreciate big big budget films or big
uh none of just escapist cinemas i don't
think that's fair but i think it's
really nice for us to
get to indulge our other side where we
can't enjoy another world for a little
while
besides our own yeah i always i'll go
see a movie too sometimes in the
afternoon and whether even if it's like
an art house
you know theater and i'm hoping that
there's going to be people
not not too many obnoxious people that
are on phones and talking and stuff
but enough where i feel like okay i'm
not the only one
and i'm gauging what they're how they're
reacting because it's not fun otherwise
no the communal experience is awesome i
mean that's a
and i guess we've talked about
straightening but i think also in film
we're going to i think people are
yearning for that communal experience
you know i think you can have your
netflix you can have your
your amazon everything people love going
to the movie theaters together
and they love watching other people
watch movies right that's the fun part
to see do they laugh at the same part
you do
are they you know if the that's the
beauty of it so i like that as well
what is the reality of distribution for
independent filmmakers today
it's rough the reality of distribution
for independent filmmakers is that
you're
you have to curb your expectations
there's only
there's so many movies out and there's
only so many
outlets for you to see them for people
to see them and everyone
even distributors on your phone are
doing their best trust me everyone wants
people to
pay that ten dollars on itunes or stream
that movie and they're all doing their
best to make that happen
so you think you have to be realistic um
during the distribution process
i think you have to be knowing that i
think you'd be very economical from the
get-go making your movies
i think you have to be very you have to
be super stringent and strict on your
budgets
and efficient and not
spending doing anything that's going to
uh
hurt the you know you have to always
take it take in consideration the
investment of your film
and at the end of the day it's very hard
to make your money back on these movies
and so if you're kind of doing it again
it goes back if you're doing that to try
to you know turn around
a quick profit it's just that's not the
reality anymore the reality is we'll get
to exist and we'll get to be out there
and you know your friends will get to
see it and audiences will
learn maybe learn to love it and that's
the reward but i think the distribution
process is very difficult
at the same time we're given a lot more
opportunity now i mean
if you look at all the films that never
never available until now
it's amazing you know all these great
revival dvd companies like
seven films and um arrow video and all
these companies that have come and
taken films that for so long were
unavailable to any of us right
bootlegs of vhs you know and they're
re-releasing them and that's really
awesome
so i think now we there you're always
going to be able to release your film
whether you you know whether you get the
best distributor you get an a24 or a
neon
or you know you get a smaller uh more
niche distributor or
you can self-distribute and i think
self-distribution is i've never done it
and i've been lucky that my last two
movies have both found distribution
but at the same time why not explore it
right like you can get one of these
aggregators i think you pay them like
1800 you know there's different tiers
you can pay in between like 1800 3 000
and they get you on all the platforms
you know so i don't think there's any
reason for your phone to
not get out there and i think at a point
you have to be very realistic
as a filmmaker and producer uh
especially for wearing both hats on the
on a smaller movie
that you someone's got to cut your
losses and just get the movie out there
and see where it lands so i think that's
the reality of it
you know i think it's it's tough because
you
it's so different now it's not the 90s
you know it's not like your film
you know you have such a you have a
better chance of getting to harvard than
you do have your film getting the
sundance
and you know amazon coming and giving
you three million dollars for a movie
and the people get that it's great and
they mostly deserve it because their
films are really good
but there's a lot of really good films
that people self-distribute that small
distributors take out
and i think as as um
i think the other thing as a filmmaker
that we have to learn is we also have to
be
our own marketers we have to understand
marketing we have to understand finding
a
niche audience and going after them
through social media
through making little fun content around
your film
trying to find a way to
break it like you can't expect anyone
else to do it for you
so i think even if you have a good
distributor so i think you really
as a filmmaker have to really you know
know that every step of this process
you're going to have to put your best
foot forward
um but there's ways to do it you know
it's just
all of it's just about kind of being
creative and
and not getting down like not letting
yourself down oh i didn't get that deal
i didn't get that
that you know those persons don't
respond my email they don't like me they
don't like it like
you can go put your film out for free
you can go put it on a website and say
hey everyone pay a dollar here's your
movie
you know there's no rules anymore which
is beautiful there's almost like an
anarchy
to film distribution so it's kind of in
your hands as the creator which is
a great thing as well that's interesting
you said that the anarchy
of film distribution because i feel like
in when kickstarter started
everyone was just so excited and
indiegogo and all that those
those platforms i think they've been
around what 10 years now and so
there was this initial excitement but
then some of the
expectation maybe wasn't totally
realistic not within those platforms
those platforms are excellent
and and i'm glad they're around it's
just once the movie's made
because i think it was like this giant
bubble and so i think that's a much more
realistic
you kind of are at this like acceptance
like you just have to kind of see where
your film's going to find its place
and and maybe that's a nice evolution to
the 10 years of
okay now that you know infamous you know
we take it from the gatekeepers and all
you know that people were using
10 years ago but then what happens yeah
okay there's no more gatekeepers but now
where does it land and so i think that's
very realistic
absolutely and queen was a kickstarter
film we raised we raised money off
kickstarter to finish the movie
and we were very lucky and i do think we
were at an end of in a bubble because i
don't think i could do that now
i think it was very much a time and
place where we were able to
motivate and really see a lot of people
that i mean people i never met
giving good chunks of change to a film
because
you know it resonated with them somehow
and that was a nice way to build a small
audience from the beginning it was
almost like a litmus test
but at the same time you can't rely on
that i was just talking to a friend
recently she's trying to do an indiegogo
and she was struggling with it it wasn't
finding its
way and i said it's not your fault it's
like you can't force these things to
happen you're asking a lot of people
so you just keep doing working hard
doing the best you can and you don't use
it you don't let it get in the way of
making your movie
but it's very hard but yes with
distribution i think it's the same thing
now where you can almost choose your
path
and if you're left with no more choices
you can do it yourself
you can just get it out there there's no
reason for your film not to be seen
you know there's no reason for it to sit
in a vault
what do you think there was a bubble
that's really interesting because i kind
of saw the same thing and those are
amazing platforms i go on there and i
see their recommendations
and i find ones that even aren't
recommended and i'm like wow this is
fantastic but it it is harder to get
uh i mean i think that you know like
anything
when it's new and fresh it's new and
fresh and then everything kind of finds
it has a cycle and then a lot of other
of these kind of
uh crowdfunding crowd sourcing sites
popped up along the way
and oh and again selling the market was
oversaturated
so there was just too many people
funding
trying to get their films made as well i
think there's been a real drop-off and i
i don't know have the statistics the
statistics but i think social media
isn't it i kind of think we saw this
whole
like equilibrium shift when it was like
the the mixture of like the trump error
the the trump error the the social media
kind of took this whole turn that where
it became much more politicized and
and we kind of had a twitter president
and then that also came to most of
kickstarter and these crowdfunding
bubbles were
a crowdfunding source with social media
so
i don't think people were maybe able to
motivate so much the the social media
aspect of it as they once were
because i think we're all just
overwhelmed i think we're just sick of
people targeting us with ads with their
asks with their
you know their gofundmes or whatever i
think we're just we're burnt out
so that's what i like i don't think it
has anything to do with kickstarter i
think it just has to do with a
a whole generation and a whole group of
the world that just
burnt out on the internet a little bit
on the same
event that had this panel of crime
writers and they were fascinating
and they were just talking about
different things and they said the thing
that
they fear most because they you know
they write about crime and some of their
their descriptions are very gruesome
what do they fear most their biggest
fear was
that the well is dry for ideas i thought
that was really interesting
the well is drive for ideas does that
ever scare you
yeah all the time i mean i think that
that we all deal with trying to tell a
unique story but it's so funny this
actually just goes back
and i keep using people's quotes but i
was reading an
interview that coppola francis for
coppola did last week
and he's 80 years old he's trying to
make a big movie
and they asked him they said what makes
an artist
as a filmmaker like as if you have any
advice to young entrepreneurial
filmmakers
or artists he goes well you want to be
an entrepreneurial filmmaker that's one
thing
but he goes if you want to be an artist
a an artist as a filmmaker
you know just start off with the one
with
the one thesis which is this
there's a one in a trillion chance that
and that this zygote was created that
created this a single individual whether
yourself
or any of the other 10 billion people on
this earth understand that everyone has
an extremely individual
story no matter who they are and you can
be an artist
and i think that goes back to the idea
of the well the well will never be dry
because every story is individual every
story is specific
and i think you know
we we just have you just as a as a
filmmaker have to
have to go out and fight to find that
story it's not always going to come to
you
but there's always a story there's
always an experience there's always
a history that someone or something has
and it's your responsibility as a
storyteller to go find it and to
manicure it and to help that it grow as
if it was a flower or garden
until it finally you know comes to
fruition
so which would you say you want to be an
artist or
an entrepreneur filmmaker
entrepreneurial filmmaker because it
seems like you almost the art the days
of the artist
it's almost like you almost can't just
be that
i mean i'd love to just be an artist
walking around with a camera
and making it better you know we all
have to pay rent
but in the end like
i don't know i've never thought of
myself as trying to be like an
entrepreneur trying to
you know reinvent the wheel i just want
to tell stories and
i hope that those stories resonate with
some people and
if along the way
you happen to be successful in business
that's amazing
um we all want to we all want to come a
more comfortable life than we have at
the moment i don't think anyone
i think even the richest people are
always looking to make their life more
comfortable and make their life better
whatever those reasons are but i just
i i like you know i i think like queen
and uh the other two films you know i i
like
i think i i have a predilection i like
focusing on people who don't necessarily
have their stories told
not as if like you know i'm not gonna go
to the homeless guy on the street and be
like i'm gonna tell your story
maybe one day but i'm just saying it's
not it's not saying it has to be
extremes
all the time um but i like
the person you know i like telling
stories about people that
in their small worlds and showing that
everyone's world is really important to
them
and everyone has their own individual
they're into
individual evolution so i don't know i
guess i want to be an artist i
i guess i'd i'd love to be sure myself
an artist but i think
you know it's a business and we're all
doing you know we all got to do business
as well how do you start a screenplay i
mean since you
since you love characters that maybe
aren't mainstream and
i am the same way i don't resonate with
a lot of like chick flicks
and it's not that it's to me i just i
can't identify with it's too perfect
for me and i don't i find myself getting
squeamish
yeah like something a little a little
more some edges around it
yeah i mean i like broken people because
i feel like one
as well yeah a lot i i like people are
conflicted um
it's so weird like how do the
screenplays are all different ways
i i can't tell you the the biggest part
of the process
it's the dumbest in the world but the
empty page is the scariest thing in the
world
so it's just like the way i start
writing is like i
say i'm a photographer as well so most
of my films
that i've written are um based off of
an image maybe that i've taken that's
kind of where i start a lot is
someone that i've captured through an
image even though the image really has
ends up having nothing to do with the
story
it's kind of like there's an image
burned into my head and i start with
that
and i allow that to take its evolution
i'm a pretty sloppy writer in that
i just start writing and i let the story
in the character the characters guide me
because i mainly write
films that are seen by a singular pov of
the main character
so because of that i kind of follow the
character and i
learn about them and as i learn about
them a plot evolves
but that's kind of how i start on a
film i'm writing it from the beginning
is i
mostly comes from an image and then that
image is mostly gives me an
idea for a character and then i follow
that character and then the world starts
to build and then i rewrite a lot
um you know sometimes
it will come you know someone goes hey i
might
you know have some money to make a movie
i have a small idea what do you think
and that
idea becomes a giant kernel
uh or because of kernel that pops and
suddenly you run with that idea because
there's a real possibility of making it
and you make it your own i mean that's a
big thing i've learned also about
filmmaking is
you got to be able to sometimes make
someone else's idea your own
and that's really interesting
process as well in its own right but for
writing with me it's it's
the image comes first and then the
character and then i follow that
character
and i find a world and i find a plot
within that character's world
and i go on the ride and i try to be the
first audience member and enjoy that
process
um i like to write fast i don't like
i never and i mean this could be also my
own detriment but i don't spend a lot of
time on a screenplay
i try to just write fast get it out push
it out there
and then then go through start going
through the rewriting process i show it
to a group of people
um that i trust or you know
or attach somehow to the project but
mainly you know you find yourself
you always need a good sounding board
and it's one of the most important
elements of the writing process and of
every of every process of the film
is having people that you can go what do
you think because like i'm lost
and you know kind of finding that nature
of
of uh people that can give you notes and
give you ideas and
tell you when you're right or wrong or
too stuck
so with queen was there an image i know
you said you were in a conflicted place
and you had to get it out but was there
an image
yeah there was a photo of a woman on
western avenue
wearing a leopard skin pro coat that i
took
uh out of the side of a car wow and
the film started with an idea of a woman
in a leopard skin coat
and was she waiting for a bus like what
was she doing
i'm not sure what she was doing it was
probably not good
she looked like
it was cool but i know the image i can
see it in my head right now
and it's actually funny enough now next
where i took the image was in front of a
church which is now next door to my
office
where i write and edit and stuff oh wow
years later
but yeah how ironic so really
interesting yeah
so that is actually really interesting
yeah it is think about it but yeah i
remember the
image and from that image but then so
it that image just spurned this
character and then the character
i pulled from my life and tons of
real life situations and scenarios and
people and then people i
other photos i had taken i took those i
wrote about those characters and
but um and some of them changed on set
like you know everything the whole
writing process is such an evolution
but yeah it really did come from a photo
out of the side of a car
uh western avenue in hollywood and
western avenue yeah
the film that you're editing now are you
able to tell us
the image that inspired it and what yeah
it's called the uh
the five rules of success and the image
that inspired it was
of a neighbor of mine who on my block
that i've lived in a long time in
hollywood
who has been in and out of prison a lot
of his life
and he's actually in there right now
he's a really cool dude um
and it was a photo that i took of him on
the street
of him lifting his shirt up and he had a
uh like a benjamin franklin tattoo that
he had just got on his stomach
and the film is about a guy who gets out
of prison
who basically follows this uh self-made
um rule book on how to find success
and to achieve his dream of opening a
restaurant after prison
so yeah it kind of came back to this
photo i take you know this guy with this
100 bill benjamin franklin tattoo who
was a good friend of mine and
spent him out of prison for a while and
how long did it take you to write the
screenplay
this one happened really fast uh this
film was kind of a trip
i had written an idea for that a very
loose idea that i had never finished a
couple years ago
and then a really uh close friend of
mine and my producer
and collaborator came to me and he was
like hey
you know i was trying to make a new
movie we didn't know really what to do
he was like i think
we can you know make moves do you have
any ideas i sent them some ideas
and then he told me you know i've had
this idea of these like five rules that
i've lived my life by
and does this inspire you in any way and
i said
absolutely it does and in about three
weeks
i wrote the script and i just holed up
and three weeks wrote the first draft of
the script and it just kind of went nuts
and it was the mixture of this story
that i had written about
my neighbor who with the with the photo
i taken of him with the benjamin
franklin
to um to we shot the film
i wrote the script in the script the
first draft was finished in november
we started shooting the film in january
so
it happened really fast and it was just
kind of like race
the whole time um so it was really cool
but yeah it just kind of like came out
of me and the way the script was written
was it to kind of be material and change
so in the edit it's been a lot of
rewriting it's been a really
kind of uh fun but tumultuous process
the editing of the film but yeah the
screenplay just like came out
it was a really cool experience to i
never made a movie this fast so
is the neighbor in the film no he's in
prison so he's still there
yeah he's he's uh he's he's still there
i think gets out in
two years but um i didn't speak to him
that long ago but no but we did
uh shoot in prison of just for a small
portion of it and stuff
and where he is no no oh i would say
yeah how'd you get acting
i was actually really bummed out i
thought the location we went to see it
was an act of prison but it wasn't
but but um yeah we filmed up in mira
loma
state uh the detention facility a
detention facility up in uh
lancaster but yeah so it's just kind of
this you know it's very much to me
it's this film is my a little bit of my
reaction to how
you you society gives you no tools to
uh really navigate it and i use the
metaphor of someone who guts out gets
out of prison it was like a blank slate
and at the same time that he's trying to
achieve something and really
putting his best foot forward society is
constantly pushing back at him
sure sure yeah i have a lot to say on
that yeah
yeah why do you think the screenplay
came so fast to you
because it goes back to the obsession
it's like it just lit a fire in me
like i just a the possibility of making
a movie like
it's so hard to get any money the idea
that there was like a real like pot of
gold at the end of the rainbow
um maybe in this case it wasn't gold
maybe it was more like bronze or
steel or who knows some sort of more
less luxury metal
and titanium yeah titanium i could only
hope
and and it was just the idea sparked so
many of my thoughts of society so many
of my thoughts of characters
and i got to just really have fun
because i was a very there was no one
telling me really
how to do it so i was like okay i'm just
gonna like be super creative have fun
write and know that there's an actually
and also
i i had set up rules like from the
get-go of
of the film and of the world because we
were already constrained from
by a budget from the day i started
writing so i couldn't it could never get
out of hand it could never
you know there could never be here's the
five million dollar version here's the
you know 50 000 version there was only
the lower budget version of the movie
so you know i had that confined me to a
certain type of uh
format and world that i got to examine
so it was uh i think that's why it came
out so fast it was almost like there
were rules set in place
already from the get-go and i had to
follow them and
that allowed me to really just push
forward through the script
and so did you just limit the locations
i know you said it was there's some in
the mira loma prison but
did you have some at an apartment or
something yeah mostly takes place i shot
half the film in my office
which we just redesigned as his
apartment it's basically most the film
is in
a apartment a armenian greek restaurant
and just streets of los angeles and
that's kind of
where it was at you know and um
i always you know everything i've made
has kind of had a uh
another obsession with just like los
angeles as a whole goes back to la land
the city is just like so schizophrenic i
love it there's just so many different
pockets different enclaves
different neighborhoods and worlds that
you get to walk through
so i kind of wanted to show that in the
movie um
i probably could have done myself a
favor and limited the locations
more uh which is definitely more has
been
a learning lesson in each film which is
to be more efficient than i was
the film before and if i i'm lucky
enough to make another film i'll try to
be more efficient
but yeah so it was about you know
writing it with those parameters and
limiting the locations
and you know limiting the amount of
characters i said you know all problems
can only be solved between these three
or four characters
there can't be characters outside of it
that come and suddenly
the story goes off with you know and
when the film is finished and it's out
there um
what do you want the conversation to be
or or
you don't have you're not tied to what
it will be
i have the reasons i made it and the
things that i want to talk about but
i i don't i i don't care what anyone
else talks about as long as they talk
about it you know i
i don't want to force their hand um i
don't think it's my place to tell them
this is what the film is about yeah i
don't want to explain it to them i i
think it's
the coolest thing is getting to to watch
something and come up
to your own idea of what it's about i
mean you know i love films
you know i love like nicholas refin only
god forgives right who the hell knows
what that movie's about
i don't know he never tells you what
it's about the film is kind of
a little uh vague but i've had so many
great conversations with people have so
many different ideas of what that movie
is about
um there's a lot of great films that
that
allow us to you kind of get to
imagine as audience members what they're
trying to say without hitting us over
the head all the time with it
so i don't know i hope people talk about
society i hope they talk about the
prison industrial complex and how
it takes advantage of of uh
of really you know hard-working good
members of society and turns them into
criminals
and you know it doesn't give them the
the proper tools necessary and i also
think it's about your own personal
agency and the idea that
you make your decisions and they're your
decisions there's no one else's
decisions
you know we have we are very lucky to be
able to have a choice
yeah but i think it's interesting what
you said i think um
about um different not having tools
you know not everybody grows up um with
the same
you know sort of uh it's not a level
playing field
and that's not to hate on one group for
having more or
having had you know i grew up without
two parents i had just one
and so and i know i grew up in a very
conservative town where seeing other
kids that did have
more it was it did do a number on me a
little bit
and so then when you're an adult then
okay how do you take those feelings and
not
turn them against yourself turn them
against other people even if they've
done you wrong and sort of contain some
of that so i think it's interesting
because i think
a lot of people in their little safe
middle class bubble they don't
understand
some of that and you make them you
almost make them a uh
you know i think a big part of what i
was trying to take from this film is
taking a guy that
almost had the the the the
deck stacked against him and making it
almost like a superpower
giving that on making that his his
experience and his you know um
the quality of life that he had lived
almost gave him an edge over other
people
and that's kind of where i was taking
this character you know made him a
little sharper made him a little harder
made him a little more um
detached from emotions in the decision
making
so in a way to me you know those those
what the world had taken from him he
uses
as his as his best tool as his greatest
tool
how did he get that superpower that's
interesting
i mean because i think that it just came
from you know
a certain amount of self-reflection and
uh intelligence and and then
and understanding of you know in this
film i think it's a
a person that's why i wanted him to kind
of create this guide for him to live by
because he saw that he had an experience
that other people didn't have
and that was going to separate him and
that's not doesn't that doesn't make it
always have to be bad you know your
experience
whether other people deem it right good
or bad doesn't mean it has to be bad
knowing that you love these sort of
characters with edges
how do you make them still redeemable
likable in some way maybe they're not
even likable but somehow that the
audience
is not going to give up on them because
they're humans
they're just like you and me that's the
point is like if you can just
get the point across that like these
people all they all sleep they all eat
you know they all breathe oxygen like
if you can just get that little point
across i think we all relate to them
it's so silly but i've always thought
about because i do like these characters
that are a little off that are a little
um you know sometimes make
it make them make the bad decisions
instead of the good decision
but i think if you also show them as
they're humans they struggle with so
many the same things we do they struggle
with how they're going to pay their rent
they struggle with did the parents love
them they struggle with all these very
human factors
if you can just show them a little of
that i think we
we can't help but relate to them um
and that's you know so i try to show
maybe people
also you know small details
in their personal life you know show a
lot of this new movie
is a guy sitting by himself in a room
eating and watching tv
because we all sit in a room and eat you
know we all
sometimes sit by ourselves and watch you
we all have trouble sleeping you know we
all have nightmares like we
these little things so i think that's
how you you just humanize them through
reality
um and also you know and i i think even
in a more
surreal movie you kind of take that
approach where you
you know you show that there's asserted
humanity behind the bad decision-making
you know behind the kind of like acting
and bad faith
type of uh decisions so that's it for me
it's just like you know if you can just
just get the point just just for a
moment across
you can get away with whatever you want
you know we there's a lot of
irreprehensible characters in cinema
that i love bad lieutenant right
oh yes bad lieutenant targo harvey
keitel is the great example of it
but in and also
you know in that film but he tries to
at one point he really feels like he's
making the right decision
and you have to show that you know you
show the human side
to the character and i think we all will
be willing to go for the ride if it's
also entertaining
you know that's a big part of it as well
yeah and i'd love to see more female
characters like that because it
you know uh margaret atwood has a great
quote and she said that
you know women are either painted as
either just total angels or just
horrible human beings but they're human
and so there's a there's a spectrum you
know whereas i think
it feels like sometimes men can have
more of a gray area but i wish they
would show
they don't have to have such clearly
defined roles of
you know either she's a bad character or
she's great but she can't be anything in
between well that was my goal with queen
i wanted to literally take a character
that we were
so accustomed with with james bonds or
robert mitchum's or
steve mcqueen's or any of these great
you know these male icons that we've had
throughout the years
and allow a woman to make those same
mistakes allow
her to to to be able to live in that
gray area that you're talking about and
that was really my goal was to take
all these characters and say why not let
a woman be it and
you know what i've had you should have
heard some of your reprehensible things
i've seen written on the
internet about her you know and that's
because people
don't it's unfamiliar because we are in
this world where
we're we're so obsessed with a man and
woman that you know women are
a lot of times relegated to these like
either they're like these
terrible evil you know the woman who's
the psycho crazy woman that destroys
everything
right um or she's the uh
you know angel love interest savior
character and there ain't no difference
we all
we're all trying to figure this life
thing out together like why can't a
woman make the same decisions that a man
makes you know it's
crazy that that media has
sold us this live for so long so yeah so
that queen
like a hundred percent and i i hope i
think i landed there i'm not sure if i
did
but i tried to let her live in this
morally gray area
and you know see how it
see how it goes and these were comments
underneath the trailer or
oh just in different comments in the
trailer
things i've heard people say to my face
things where people
you know the friends that that just
didn't even realize they were kind of
saying something that was you know it's
beyond not misogynistic it's just
unaware of what they were saying about a
character
she's so hard you know yeah she's like
she's such a
right i go really because like if james
bond did that
you wouldn't say that you know if if
if um you know when ryan gosling
punches uh uh god
just like the one actress in the face
and drive no one ever asked about it
no one ever said you know but when
if she does it you know if she slaps
another person
suddenly she's like evil sometimes she's
cringe-worthy
and uh yeah no we got a lot you know
we've gotten a lot of great reviews but
we had a few people that really like
went on the misogynistic terrain on the
film interesting
yeah and good that's what i wanted i
want them to
show their face yeah show your face
that's what you think
say it you know yeah that's conversation
so then there again you can't control
the outcome of the film and it's
it's it lands where it lands you know
yeah
what makes a protagonist or a hero great
i think what makes a protagonist hero
great is
that they make
bad decisions and good decisions i think
we need i think what you even have seen
in the recent
i think what really resonated the people
about the marvel cinematic universe over
the last 10 years and i use that as like
you know those are the biggest
protagonists in the world that we've
ever had is that they were all flawed
and i think that's why so many people
related to them around the world
with these characters and they weren't
perfect characters and i think
so that's from the top down right so i
think in a protagonist it's showing
that there's flaws there's chinks in the
armor and everyone puts up the front
that everything's okay and that they're
strong and that they're confident but
they all struggle with their own inner
monologues and their own weaknesses so i
think it's you know it's really showing
um kind of uh the the faults
in the in the follies of those
characters and that they
also make bad decisions but i think
what's great about
what really makes a great character and
protagonist is showing that they have uh
also a code a moral
a moral compass i think that's really
important even to bad
even to when your character is an
antagonist they got to have a code or
moral compass
characters without any just who wants to
watch that
do you remember the first film that you
saw that that had a
a challenged protagonist that that was
flawed but you
you resonated with and i think it was
the first batman with michael keaton
i think i always kind of like understood
because he was just like an arrogant
you know kind of you know elitist guy
but he had
so much of his own demons that he was
struggling with a movie really resonated
with me
as a kid um
i don't know i always think about the
first batman was like a very
influential movie when i was you know
eight nine years old
beyond that um
[Music]
i don't know i've always i fell in love
so much with flaw protagonists along the
way i mean
like taxi driver changed my life like
that film is my favorite movie i love it
and you know travis bickle
is a really interesting character
because he so believes he's
right and everyone else is wrong that
he ends up committing a basically a
heinous act of violence but becomes
rewarded for it
and i think that's so interesting to me
about him is like
he was right you
he might seem psychotic and crazy to you
and because we've been able to live with
him for two and a half hours but
to the rest of the world he's a hero so
i love those characters you know
so that was probably the most major
influential one on anything i've ever
tried to make
did you see the movie smooth talk with
laura dern no
and treat williams yeah but i love both
of those oh you got to see it so
she's she's a it's probably not totally
pc but i love that film
and i thought you know she was not
totally flawed but she
you know was pushing the envelope a
little and she was
challenged in some ways i don't want to
give away no you got to check it out
i want to say 80s awesome yeah
it's really good it's definitely not a
totally pc movie but
um i'm okay with that yeah
what's your advice to directors for
shooting out of chronological order
i'm not sure if you had to do that much
with them no actually it's so funny
so my first um i i i was very lucky
in my film trespassers the horror film i
made which comes out this summer
um it's a contained thriller it only
takes place in one house
in in in the desert and i got to shoot
almost
90 of the film in chronological order
that was a treat
on the other hand i've made my two other
films they've both been out of
chronological order
so it's a very hard
it was something that i didn't realize
how hard it was going to be until i sat
in the editing room after making queen
my first film
and i looked at all the mistakes i had
made because it's very hard to gauge an
actor's performance from one
scene to the next if you're shooting the
first part of that scene
that monday and then you shoot the next
part of that scene two weeks from then
so you know you shoot them in the room
that monday but then you shoot them in
the car driving away from it two weeks
later
and you have to somehow in your mind um
and be able to go back to that scene and
figure out where they were
i found there's a few different
methods that i even try to use
throughout
at least um you know now after going
through that process
the first method was my second phone i
got to shop shoot mainly in
chronological order
which was amazing and that really makes
life easier
because you get to come up with things
you get to come up with new ideas you
have to rewrite as you go
then in my la the film i'm making right
now five was of success i had to go back
because
of uh financial situations into a more
out of order block shooting situation
and i actually
one of the tools i used was on
halloween john carpenter he had
a meter that he would use for jamie lee
curtis which was like her intensity
meter
since they were shooting out of order so
be like hey we're at this level in
this scene okay we got to go back to
level five i didn't have a meter but on
my script
when i went through beforehand and was
prepping i had
basically given like different notes to
myself on what intensity they would have
to be during that scene
so when i would get the shot list of
that day and have my
sides i would refer back to my script at
like where they were supposed to be in
that scene
because what scene were they coming from
it's very hard though i think shooting
out of order is a
super hard
technical process and i definitely by no
means have
understood it or claimed to um
i'm still learning a lot with how to do
it and i really wish i had
the privilege of being able to shoot
chronologically every time because it
makes your life a lot easier
but it's just you know it's all about
prep and it's just about
fixing the prep know that when you're
making doing your pre-production when
you're doing your shot list
when you're doing your schedule um
making notes to yourself that you can
always refer to
about where they're supposed to be
talking with your actor making sure that
you're both on the same page
beforehand rehearsing um you know making
sure you're
taking the time with the actor before a
lot of it also is like and i guess this
is something we haven't really talked
about but
working with an actor is such a big part
of this process and
it's really making sure everyone does
their homework individually
and then we all come together and we're
checking our homework and our notes
together
so we're all in a similar place or at
least
willing to allow someone to be in a
place that they want to be and
creating that environment so yeah a big
part of it is just like prep
rehearsing with the actor giving notes
making sure you're kind of on the same
page with your notes where you're at
with the script
you know breaking down the if you kind
of break down the beat that's why i love
doing a shot list
i don't even follow my shot list most
the time when i'm shooting
but i like it because it allows me to
break down the beats of every scene
and if i know where the beats are i know
where i need to be so i can go hey we
did shoot the scene in your apartment
three weeks ago
and now we're in the restaurant in the
next scene remember you're coming out of
it you're all upset this
just happened this is where we were you
know let's try to get back there
and um also your head you're your
costume designer
in your wardrobe are really important in
this process
because they're mostly always are super
on it about
where you know continuity and where the
actor is
and what outfit they're in so that
outfit really can dictate
to the actor a lot of where they need to
be so
it's kind of you like using all the
tools and people around you as well to
help guide
the process so you make a shot list but
you don't really refer to it you almost
it's like almost intuitively it's like a
blueprint already inside of you
oh yeah like i always have it with me on
set but i don't really look at it but if
you look at the shots they're almost
identical to what i write in the shot
list
i just kind of you know use it as a
process to break down beat by beat each
scene in the film
and then once you get there things
change you know things change you want
to do something totally different
you see the scene you're gonna go let's
just do this all in one shot take
you know there were scenes i would have
a ton of coverage for and then i'd be
like i just want to do one take and i'll
you know i just want to do it as a
warner and we'll see where we land and
if it works it works you know um
it's just all about your own process and
you learn about it as you go but yeah
i do the shot list but i don't uh
storyboard and i don't
you know refer to each shot when i
uh start doing the scene and in queens
she has the leopard skin jacket right
yeah i think because i think she's the
largest yeah yeah in the trailer yeah
yeah very cool
where'd you get the jacket by the way oh
i got it off etsy oh nice
and crazy was i found two doubles of it
from two different cellars
i found it about three days before
shooting maybe four days so i had to
have them rush delivered
and that was good because there's a lot
of blood in the movie so allowed want me
to have one blood jacket
one non-blood jacket but like in queen i
really struggled with some continuity
issues because of my uh i hadn't made a
lot of short films beforehand so i kind
of had
you know a little bit of an amateur um
awareness of continuity and of you know
shooting out a chronological order
so it really is a huge leap then because
people always say oh it's not you know
if you've done a several shorts it's
just you're just doing a longer version
of it it sounds like it's not the case
no
it's it's a whole other beast and it's
not i actually really respect people
that can tell something really fast and
succinct in three to five
to ten minutes in a short film i've
never been good at that but no maybe you
know making a feature as a
you're creating a whole world you've got
to build that world and then you've got
to
hide every single mistake you made in
that whole process
from the audience so in the end of the
day they're not sitting there picking it
apart they're getting to go on the ride
where did where did you get the strip
club from or did you did you piece that
together
um the exterior is well i i
came i had the name of it first it was
called queen mary's then i found out
there was an exterior of a strip club in
portland oregon
and we shot the exterior up there and
then the interior was in glass of park
at this
great place uh lisken delays and it was
a really long process to find the strip
club
i went to so many of them along the way
i have like all these great photos of
just empty strip gloves in the middle of
the day as location photos
yeah there's one that i've driven by in
the valley i won't say what it is but
they have the most interesting like
advertising
like hey guys easter special you know
and then i'm like somebody's really like
they must have like some social media
person or whatever because they they're
i'm actually like fascinated by their
advertising
hey they know how to get you they're
gonna get you you know
is there anything about filmmakers that
bothers you like
excuses in terms of when you hear people
say
they're trying to get funding and it's
like their first feature and
they're trying to make this huge film
and they're using that as like this
excuse and they're they're waiting for
it to happen when like
oh just make this keep it smaller and
then
move on to that i i think i think the
it's something that bothers me i just
think you know when you're trying to
make
a movie it's different because there's
some movies you can't make for a small
budget right
like it's it's very hard to make films
on a little money
and it's very hard to raise a lot of
money so you're kind of in this
double-edged sword
but i i think the one thing i find with
filmmakers is
when they get obsessed with
the budget and they get obsessed with
reaching some number
instead of being like i gotta make this
movie
how do i make this movie how do i make
this movie for ten thousand dollars how
do i make this movie for ten million
dollars you know
and if you can't make the movie for 10
million dollars
maybe there's another film you can make
for 10 000 and you should think about
that
and i think it's just that's if your
goal is
it may be maybe all you want to do is
make that 10 million dollar film so
that's fine to focus on it
there's any right way you know they're
very different beasts
to make but i think we get very obsessed
with budgets
as filmmakers and i think we need to
[Music]
i think you know the you can't let the
budget constrain your creativity
let the budget allow you to be more
creative sometimes less money
means you have to you know let's say
they say necessity is the mother of
invention right
and that's how i feel about filmmaking
is that if you got no money
figure out how to make it interesting
for no money you know and
i think that's the thing don't let you
know don't let the number get in the way
of you telling the story
at the same time it's hard to
get movies made and it's hard to get
financing and no one's going to knock
you if you can't figure it out
so it's kind of on you in the end of the
day
was it harder to make queen or was it
harder to get
subsequent projects made
i've been really lucky honestly i can't
i can't like
um queen was pretty was was
the hardest one probably to make because
because i hadn't i hadn't made anything
so it was like there was no there was no
proof in the pudding yet
so i really had to just like me and my
mat
and jeff and gracie and alec and all the
people that were like with me from the
beginning
we just kind of had to like with
tenacity as a group
really pushed this film into getting
made
um because no one was going to give it
to us after that
after i got that made you know i got
another film not long after that where
people came to me that was already
funded and that was really amazing
so i've gotten lucky since then honestly
and i feel very grateful for
for what i the people that have taken
chances on me
but the first one was definitely the
hardest to get made
were there moments when you weren't sure
you want to make a second or that was
never
that never entered your mind
i definitely there was most where i
thought i never want to make a movie
ever again
uh i think i think about that almost
every day
this is it's like you know it's like
there's a little bit of a torment of
doing this where it's
it it ev you know
it never feels like getting paid enough
it never feels like it's it
it's it's what you envisioned it to be
you know you always
to me like always the idea of what the
film is and what the film becomes it
never
you know it doesn't always equal the
same but it's just plugging away at it
you know
it's it is what it is but i never wanted
to
i don't know what else i could do that's
the problem i just have no
other idea what in the world i would do
to make movies and if that got taken
away with me i would truly be
uh listless and not know where to go
so yeah i definitely was like i don't
know if i want to make a second one i
don't know if i want to go this process
again this sucks
but it's like who am i to to say that
when it's
i get to make movies and have fun and i
get to be on set with my friends and
you know it's we're really lucky to get
to do this at least once
do you keep up with the people that you
went to film school with
yeah i'm really close some of my
collaborators are people i went to film
school with
my dp of queen luke hanlon we went to
emerson together
and my composer daniel delaura on both
my films
uh and he gave me a song for my other
movie we went to college together so
and then a lot of people in my class you
know it's kind of amazing to see a lot
of
people that i was very close with become
really successful in film it's
it's cool like i'm i'm really excited to
see people that i know
achieve and evolve as filmmakers and
artists and
any facet of your creativity and see
them you know getting
accolades for it is really cool did you
see them make
a feature right out of school or or
continue to make more
only one only one group of friends made
a feature outside of school and it
actually did quite well it went to south
by
it did well and they've done two more
since then and they're
writers on some great shows and but yeah
i mean you know they all were just but
these were kids you know
you saw it in school you honestly you'd
see it in their
work they were all really talented
people and their talent just evolved
over time and they figured it out
so yeah i'm still really close with a
lot of people i went to school with
yeah i was just wondering i mean i
didn't go to film school but i was
curious if most people end up making
multiple features afterwards
or they just work in the industry
they're that to them that
that's satisfied they want to just be
you know whatever it is
somewhere within the industry not making
their own film well i think we're all
a lot of our goal is to make our own
film but we all have to work like i'm
not making a living off
filmmaking all the time which a lot of i
think they are as well but they're all
finding
work in the industry that also allows
them to maybe make a movie make a tv
show
or something that nature and some people
don't want to make movies you know they
kind of get burnt out on it and they
move on to doing something else you know
i think it's
you know i you again you got to be crazy
to want to make movies it is it is a
crazy art form and you can get lucky and
make a movie or you can go
20 years trying to get one movie made
and it never gets made you know and
and maybe it does 20 years from now you
see these stories
uh recently with filmmakers you know
like i wanted to make this film for
10 15 years and i never made a movie
then i made it and suddenly it's a
you know sundance so there's there's no
i don't think there's a right
uh evolution for any filmmaker out there
that's true when you say being crazy do
you think
just have people try to talk you out of
this yeah my whole life
my like i know you said your dad my dad
did my friends have
uh you know girlfriends in the past have
been like you know why you
why do you want to like be poor all the
time
but uh you know um
and it just fritz but you know at the
same time people
i think a lot of people have also stood
by me at times where it's been very
difficult
you know and help support me in
different ways and
you need a community behind you to do
this and been really supportive
when you're making the film like in all
different ways like that
that's the magic of film is watching all
these people some of them that you've
never met before
coming together to help you and it's not
like you know at least on the films
i'm making they're not getting paid that
much they can definitely go somewhere
else and get paid better
and they're all talented enough to do
that but they all kind of come together
for a common goal
but yeah and you know what and there's
haters out there
like you know there's people that just
don't want to see you do
what you love where you succeed and you
just gotta like you know just let that
go one ear and out the other it's not
your problem
you know you gotta be steadfast in what
you believe in this so
well that's how we found you is someone
someone tweeted it i don't you wasn't
your
they included your twitter handle i
think what was neil oh okay
was it what i think it was without your
head
oh it was that interview you told me um
when i did in boston underground with my
friend
neil he does a punjabi yeah that was a
good one where you were there with your
mom
yeah yeah i liked that one it was great
i like that one yeah
but yeah so someone else tweeted it and
i saw it came through our feed somehow
and then yeah that's awesome
but that's like again that goes back to
like you know the network like you gotta
just
it grows and people support you and you
support each other and you never
know who's to find who or who's going to
see what
you know you got to have faith in the in
the audience and the network
right and the algorithm yeah
was there anything else you entertained
doing aside from making films or maybe
you could make them on the weekends
no i honestly have no like there was
like i do photography
and art and obviously like i work in
like
making content and stuff for different
companies or whatever to make
a living but it's still all around the
image
basically i realized that i had no other
career besides in the image making
industry
at a young age because i literally have
no other skill in the world
like i don't know what else i could do
i'm not
very good with my hands like i don't
think i could be like building
bookshelves for a living or something
like that and
i don't really have any other skill set
besides
making images so i have
no clue i'd probably be like a delivery
boy somewhere
or maybe um
i i really don't like it's so funny like
i just i couldn't imagine
going into a different industry besides
making films and making
photos and telling stories um i'd love
to teach
that's something that i really like
would want to
do at a point um because i really love
talking about film and i love
talking to other like you know helping
in any way guide people in their
experience with it so that would be a
real
love but no i got to do this it's like
it's kind of like
this or like you know the grave so
did you ever have another job where you
realize that um i mean i've worked you
know odd jobs along the way
but honestly from when i was about 17
i started working in an equipment rental
house like i really like
took like the the first job i could get
in the film industry
um even you know honestly having my dad
who was in film and stuff
but i went a different route where i was
like i'm going to work in like the
equipment rental house
unloading and loading cable and sandbags
and lights
and that's where i started and from that
you know
i knew that if nothing else i was happy
just doing that
just being that close to the film world
was amazing
so from there you know i got lucky i got
i've paid i remember
it was it was really amazing at one
point the one of the
uh production companies that helped fund
queen
um and gave me was really nice give me
some money towards it
i when i first started off with them i
used to scrub their bathrooms
and clip their hedges you know so like
you never know
and that's kind of another side of this
is um for me it was i
and my mom was really supportive about
that she was like yo
you you gotta support yourself we're not
wealthy like you gotta figure it out but
don't
take a job outside of the film industry
and
i think that was a really good point
from her to give me so it was like
yeah i was doing laborious jobs but they
were always still
in this industry and going through it
and learned something
in every facet or met someone in every
facet that helped me you know
when i was working at the equipment
rental house i used to
get make deals with them to allow me to
use their equipment for free on the
weekends to make music videos
and that's where i kind of started so
you never know it's all opportunities
but
i have no clue what else i would do if i
couldn't
be in this industry and this was in new
york right yes this was back in new york
so then you went to emerson and then
once you graduated from emerson
did you come to la i was in new york for
a year and then i came out here to work
on a documentary
and then i uh i didn't ended up getting
paid on that documentary
and i didn't have money to get back so i
ended up sleeping on matt berkowitz's
couch was my best friend
you also did an interview with oh wow
and i stay on his couch for a long time
and his mom used to sometimes buy us
groceries you know once a week so we
would live off like the frozen food she
would buy us
and started taking odd jobs so yeah
after college it kind of
that's how it happened so i kind of
ended up in l.a yeah so your plan was to
go back but then
because the money didn't come through
yeah didn't come through and then my
life just kind of started here you know
and then
life happened
what's the best screenwriting book
you've ever read i've never read a
screenwriting book
but i've read a lot of screenplays and
that's so funny i've never read a
screenwriting book i've tried and i just
like i can't relate to them but i've
read a ton of screenplays actually since
i was a kid i read screenplays
there used to be this guy in union
square in new york
that would boot legs help bootleg
printed out copies of the screenplays
um that's great yeah and i remember
buying the goodfellas one
and that was really influential i mean
when i was a kid and taxi driver
and um so i was just reading all of
these screenplays
over time and uh cone blood simple
cone brother screenplays were really uh
influential
and so that's what i learned from was
reading a lot of screenplays not really
books on them
and watching tons of movies but yeah so
this guy i'm sorry i'm just fascinated
but did he have like a booth set up
oh yeah like a whole table and it would
have like i could see it now like
all these like different screenplays
that were brassed and bound they have
like these
neon yellow or pink like highlighter
colors on the front
and these like bad printouts of the film
so it'd be like the bad vhs cover of
like the godfather
and then it would be the whole script
though it's basically somehow he got his
hands on the script and he would
have them xerox they were like terrible
xeroxes and they were like two or three
bucks and i buy them i had stacking them
and
like read them and since i was a young
age that's kind of like
how i got into it and you said
goodfellas was the first one
i really remember reading um
like from him and then from them and i
still have tons of screenwriting uh
my screenplays that you know i still get
you know i i just was reading the um
the counselor screenplay by cormac
mccarthy which is a film not many people
love
the screenplay is absolutely phenomenal
it's actually see it
almost you could see it as an example of
a screenplay that is
so good it makes it it was too almost
too good to become a movie
you know because it's so well written
why do you think it because it doesn't
there's not enough showing
it well yeah because it's all on the
page like so much if it's on the page
in the screenplay it's in so much if
it's like the inner monologue in the
dialogue
you know he's such a good novelist like
the dialogue when it gets spoken
doesn't have the same effect as when you
read it in his screenplay
the way the dialogue just like sits with
you and stings you and just
comes out but i love the film either way
but the
screenplay is really something but yeah
i love reading screenplays but yeah i
never really read like
like save the cat or anything like that
yeah i just it
it's probably why my screenplays are all
a little disjointed
well you know it's funny maybe that's
your next idea is the some guy that's in
you said times square or union square
you know
oh union square okay time different yeah
sorry
time square would be amazing i'm
picturing a guy with like a trench coat
that's hey i've got these necklaces here
you know
i mean it's pretty close like it wasn't
far from that he was definitely like
some like haitian dude who was just like
hey screenplay screenplay screenplay
because like only in new york could that
be some sort of side hustle
i love it oh man that's great
how did you digest it how do you feel
that that was helpful for you
i i didn't really i don't think like
deconstruct them i just kind of
they just sat with me and things that i
and what i loved about it you know like
it
it was kind of like it was just to kind
of get an understanding of the language
and understanding of
of the format and because i loved
most of the screenplays i read i had
seen the movies of so it was kind of
almost like
yeah i guess it was the screenplay
itself is a deconstruction of the film
so it was almost like i got to go
backwards and see where they started
and then i could fill in the blanks of
how they ended up there
and i became really obsessed with like
the lore of how films were made
like i loved reading hollywood stories
or production stories
so i think that became that kind of like
fill in the gap area
but um that's where i kind of a lot of
what i learned from was like watching
movies
and then reading the movies and then
reading how the movies were made
and between that i think i hopefully
picked up a few things
did you see sunset boulevard yeah i love
sunset well queen is very much
based off sunset over yeah i love sunset
boulevard
yeah i didn't find her character that um
horrible i just felt it was a good
representation of you know because she
started what at seventeen
engineers sort of gloria swanson mm-hmm
and uh i love i love the scenes where
all the photos on the wall and
everything are of her
and that that's her whole world is is
she is did nothing exist outside of that
you know just
yeah there's a great scene where she
goes to the front gate of the studio you
know and they're like who are you like
we're not gonna let you
in and um what success will be demille
is like
it's gloria swanson you have to let her
in like you know it's like
um and it is amazing that film that
shows that fall from grace and
it's such a great intricacy and you know
they made that film they were writing
the screenplay as they were shooting it
oh wow that they didn't go in with a
full screenplay of that movie billy
wilder and i remember who this co-writer
was
so it's kind of amazing that that film
has this very
improvisational side that you would
never realize
and the way it was made because he's
writing the screenplay too
and sees her as like the meal ticket but
yeah it's very interesting
yeah and then uh what's your his name
who plays her
butler oh he was fantastic yeah he was
her enabler
and he was his direct she he's i can't
remember forgetting his name right now
the blue angel
max you put it in a cryo okay
at some point but uh he was the uh he
was the director
and so he played her butler right it was
also you find out her husband
and in real life he had directed her in
movies
and they had a very like kind of almost
like abusive director actress
relationship
so billy wilder was like almost like an
inside joke for him to put him as the
uh as the subservient to her
interesting right yeah and he also sort
of cleaned up everything and well i
don't want to give away too much
with the letters and everything just
sort of if you have not seen sunset
boulevard
stop this interview and go watch this at
so i understand that cgi blood in horror
films
is one of your pet peeves i do not like
cgi blood
i i'm not gonna lie i have used some
when i've had to
you know mainly for clean up but i uh
i hate when i see it in the film and it
does not age well
like if you watch a film that would look
maybe you thought look really good
six years ago and they did a bunch of
fake cgi blood
and you look at it now it just it does
not look real there's no shine to it
there's no
i mean there's tons of shine to it
there's no texture it all
moves in that weird cg algorithm
actually honestly i'm like i'm so over
through cgi at this point i can't tell
you enough i watched the matrix the
other day and that film stands up
so well against any big budget
blockbuster from today
and you go watch like avengers and i'm
just i'm so disappointed in the way it
looks
because it's all just in a green screen
nothing's practical half the time
they're not even wearing the outfits
that they put on into the movie and
it just it's very hard for me to lose
myself in that world
when it just doesn't have the same
tangibility you know you even go back
and look at early
highlander films they're all matte
paintings and these beautiful you know
backdrops that are hand-painted and you
really feel that you know it's it's
it's got such a fantastical sense to it
but it's still
recognizable because it's not made by
computer imagery and so i
really i don't like cg that much in
general
but i really don't like blood i love
practical effects
and trespassers we did some really cool
practical effects which people
you know um i think people will really
dig i mean there's a couple violent gags
that i'm like
super proud of and we cleaned it up a
little bit digitally it's an amazing you
know
you got to use the tools that we have to
to
to you know i like i don't think it's
bad to use digital to you know
emphasize or add on or take away but
i just love the way practical blood
really works
and um i i love
you know watching it get everywhere and
people i don't even love when you're
making the film it gets on everything
everyone's hands everyone's clothes
everyone's
like i got blood on me like this is fun
air that comes into the
set because there's blood everywhere um
and yeah i like i like blood
but not 3d blood any other pet peeves
uh pet peeves that i have um in terms of
how like films are made in
recent years uh when
when actors are clearly not in the same
room with each other
and they try to fake it trick us that
they are and it gets like really
that's really starting to bother me a
lot lately um
and it's understandable i mean it's
impossible to schedule all these giant
stars together
but i just want to see them um you know
i i just want to see it's hard for me to
get lost in those
moments uh obviously i think that you
know once you make a movie or two you're
kind of looking at it in a little
different
a little more cynical light watching
other people's movies
um i love guns in movies but i'm a
little over
the kind of like endless shootout uh
shootouts that go on in a lot of movies
i like the john wick films and all that
stuff but
it's just in today's uh climate i think
it's a little irresponsible as
filmmakers to make
you know so much gun porn yeah i don't
mean that i'm someone that
has used guns in every single film i've
made and
i'm not saying i'm not a uh i'm not
flagrant of doing that as
well but it's something that i've at
least started to think about as a
filmmaker and has really stood out to me
um a big pet peeve i have i hate scenes
that just drive the plot
you know i think plot when i think a lot
of times plot gets in the way of a good
story
and that's something that bugs me a lot
and you see it a lot in kind of uh
in this like new globalist cinema that
we've entered where
a lot of films are made for around the
world i think
we try to push plot down people's
throats where i think
we're not giving enough credit to the
global audience that they're actually
like
really smart and they want strong
characters over
big plots um so that's a big thing to me
yeah those are kind of my pet peeves i
mean you know in china
everyone talks about oh they're making
movies for china well in china a movie
called
kaepernick which was a really small
independent art house film that came out
i can't remember out of which country
um made more money than shazam there
this year
and another film long day's journey into
night which i loved
made more money than the first than the
last avengers movie there
and these are very esoteric art house
films so
i think we need to re-examine
as western filmmakers the idea of like
global audience and how we're
trying to always push plot and try to
push simplicity down people's throats
rather than allowing the audience to
think for themselves
when you say that you've used guns in
all of your films
how do you feel that going forward maybe
filmmakers should be more responsible
i think that i think that we
we as a society guns we have a
sickness in this country and
i think with regarding guns and i think
we just need to show that they have
effects
it doesn't mean you don't use them it
just means that they have consequences
and to be honest about the consequences
of a gun and i think that's all you have
to do you know i don't think a con
i think for a long time guns and cinema
were considered
a source of masculinity or strength i
don't
see that as the case anymore um
i also think you can be a lot more
creative finding other great weapons in
movies to hurt people with
so that's another fun thing i think that
people should be taking advantage of a
gun's a very easy solution
to you know a more maybe creative
fun uh action sequence
than just you know someone shooting
someone you can really
find another way to do that really well
did you see that in a lot of indonesian
movies like the raid or uh
killers or night comes for us or this
stuff but yeah i think we just have to
remember
that we have we are going to put
something out that's going to be live
out there and going to be seen by people
and that
violence and guns do have consequences
and we shouldn't
take that lightly we we wield a certain
type of power as filmmakers
and we're lucky to do this and we
shouldn't be that irresponsible if we
want to be irresponsible then we should
own that irresponsibility
and you know if you want to just make
irreverent films and just kill everyone
that's great that's what your film is
going to be about though and that's
that's cool that's your
that's what you're saying you know so
yeah
you think of a film where it's
irreverent but
there is a responsible i don't want to
say message i think it's a bad
connotation but
a film that that shows something in a
healthier light an unhealthy situation
in a more responsible light
yeah i mean i think that like
irreversible right a film that
um has one of the most like intense
violent
what some people say gratuitous scenes
uh people have ever seen i think it does
a lot
to talk about the conversation and i
think it's it's not
the gasparno is no dummy and i think you
have to remember that when you watch a
film like that and you have to
be willing to discuss what it's talking
about
i think it's very okay to bring a
reverent subject matter to light i think
people
need that i don't believe in political
correctness and i don't believe in
censorship whatsoever
so yeah but i do think that you have a
responsibility
and you can't get mad when people react
to it
you know so yeah do you think you'll
ever make
a romantic comedy or the other side of
la la land i know you you made one side
but
do you think that'll ever be in your dna
to make something
light and fluffy like that absolutely
actually like my
i have like a crazy idea in my head like
i really i i think my next film i want
to do is like
more of like i want to do something like
a comedy and a little more fun
i think the the world's gotten dark
enough and i want to do something with
some levity next
so yeah like i actually i mean my dream
would be to make a film in every genre
i think that's like you know as a genre
a lover like i love genre films i think
all genres have a great
way of communicating different aspects
of life so i'd love to do like a comedy
like a kind of punch drunk love-esque
you know um
dark comedy or something like that um i
just saw the beach bum recently by
harmony corinne
and he had said something similar where
he was like in the he was a q a with him
and he was like you know all my films
have been so dark
like the world had gotten way too dark
for me so i wanted to make something
that had a little light in the world
and i watched when i cried because i the
character was so beautifully
constructed and poetic in its beautiful
outlook on life
and and um you know he was actually like
always trying to be the best he could be
and and so yeah i would love to make
something that was
fun and exciting and adventurous and
you know human and not necessarily
bogged down i actually i because this
new film the five rules of success
i think it has a great message in it but
it's a pretty dark struggle the guy goes
it's a journey
and uh it's even personally affected me
so i think the next time you know i want
to take a break
not only um psychologically from my own
well-being but
just also like what i want to put out
there i think i'm gonna do something
more fun more like
uh funny i don't know i've always wanted
to write a comedy so i
have an idea that i hopefully next i
could do is something that's more
lighthearted and
i know maybe something that's not r
or nc 17 rated
just real just skimming the surface a
little bit without going too deep into
it why did it affect you personally
you're spending a lot of time living in
the head of a guy that just got out of
prison
and is sitting in a room by himself and
he's a very silent guy
you spend a lot of time trying to tell
people what he's thinking inside
and i think and you're dealing with
death you're dealing with
the film deals with a lot of childhood
trauma stuff like that
um any image or sound that
is out there affects you so when you're
taking it in at such a high velocity
you know it just starts affecting you
and you know i did my first film queen
is a pretty violent uh intense kind of
like dark odyssey
trespassers is a super violent horror
thriller
um and deals some pretty dark subject
matter and then this film you know which
i think is actually
out of the three probably the more
positive
in its messaging at the same time
it you know you you're following a
pretty
uh guy you know trying to navigate a
kind of dark world
so i think for me it's just
spending a lot of time you know i'm
editing the film by myself so a lot of
times just me alone
with that film and with that world and
i'm actually editing the film in the
room we shot a lot of the film in so
there's this whole meta
go it's going on so i think next i'm
gonna do something fun and like
if you know if i'm ever allowed to make
a movie again
what is more fun and more light-hearted
and uh
i don't know you know maybe a little
more
family-friendly meet the i love
meet the
fantastic so insane like i love those
like do like an action movie that's like
kind of fun like a buddy
like a buddy i'm dying to do like a
buddy comedy like that's like next like
i really
want to do like a fun uh kind of
outrageous buddy comedy and we'll see
where
it lands you know i think you'll be
allowed to make another one
thank you